hey reject nation Greg Alva here John
we're gonna do another episode of
trailers revisited trilogy visited is
when we look at trailers for movies
we've already seen that have come out a
while ago we mainly go off request for
these and we determine how accurately
portray the movie is or if it's spoiler
if ik or you know whatever tone gets
communicated it's a fascinating analysis
to do before we do that I want to say a
quick thank you to everyone who's been
joining our patreon we've had a lot more
people join the patreon community of the
reject nation over the past few days so
thank you to everyone over there over
there we do weekly Q&A is meaning we do
video responses to any question you guys
put down so I like we do a bunch we take
one question at a time
make a video out of it and the other
thing that we do is full-length TV show
reactions right now on my own I'm a
covering attack on Titan I'm catching up
on the flash Jon's covering Riverdale
Marvel's run away he's gonna probably do
some episodes of Atlanta maybe together
we're doing my hero academia which just
started Jessica Jones season 2 where you
also cover Black Lightning together
every once in a while we do like other
things like music videos because it was
usually get blocked on YouTube so thank
you to everyone and speaking of patreon
patron today shout out for Delia
Chamberlain today anyway let's take a
look at this trailer this is the second
trailer by the way so the first one's
just a teaser in a way you know
I haven't seen his trailer in so many
years
[Music]
director fury I think it's time
[Music]
here with mission trying to see
doctor I need you to come in
[Music]
baby-faced
[Music]
it'll call on such lost creatures
you made me very desperate
[Music]
this bass a watching this chair ever
alright
sorry they give that away
we're seeing that shot of the Train oh
wow it's fascinating watching the
Infinity Ward further than watching this
[Music]
[Music]
interesting yeah interesting how that
trailers communicated I remember the
first time I saw the footage for this
because the way the film is shot the way
it's framed and the quality of the
camera looked very different than all
the other Avengers movies that had come
out at that time and it still does like
there's a very specific look this film
has I remember thinking when I first saw
that looks a little cheesy
kind of corny to me the first time I saw
it I was one of the people who would see
this trailer and go I really want to see
this I'm excited for it but I'm also
like really nervous is the first time
they're all coming together yeah yeah
like then if this like there was no
guarantee it was gonna go right and if
it doesn't go right like how much of a
bummer how kind of embarrassed yeah how
much of a letdown would that be you and
this is also at that time and like I had
a similar way heavier with the Iron Man
3 trailer a complaint that we did for it
was revisited in terms of how serious of
a trailer that was the Avengers movie I
think the thing that people were
delightfully surprised by was how funny
this movie was and this was around the
time I think it was when the Avengers
came out when they started implementing
a lot of humor into their films because
Joss Whedon's staple of the humor and
the banter that really had a lingering
effect that played into like all the
Marvel movies preceding after this film
majority of them I know there's like
exceptions like Black Panthers not
hilarious or Winter Soldier in Civil War
aren't like the funniest things ever but
a lot of other Marvel movies are really
funny this movie had so much humor in it
whose is not communicated in its trailer
yeah they hint it like an aspect that
feeds the humor because I was kind of
surprised and going back to revisit is
that what they're hyping it seems like
the most are the battle obviously but
the dysfunction of the team yeah and
that feeds both the conflicts of the
movie and a lot of the humor of the
movie and yeah a little surprised that
this isn't as humorous a trailer
especially knowing that it's Joss Whedon
and knowing like and knowing I mean
funny the movie is yeah yeah it's like
everything that Joss Whedon touches
practically has a certain destructive
humor on it because even when they're
showing like these images of Iron Man
and Thor fighting each other here
they make it look like it's a serious
showdown of a conflict when when you
look at that scene that's just a really
fun scene to watch those two go out it
is making his jokes it has a serious
moments of course it does the big thing
about it that really did precede a lot
of the other Marvel movies was how funny
the movies decided to become after Joss
Whedon had this and it was such a
massive success and the big thing that
grabbed that people gravitated towards
was how funny in the movie was - in
terms of like a trailer not really
revealing a lot I think it does a really
good job of that yeah yeah it's mostly
just like clip it's here and there from
different like action scenes and then
narrations that kind of get the point
across yeah like if you were to do like
a trailer breakdown you could kind of
piece some things together
there are moments from all over the
movie when Loki is talking about like
you work with these creatures or
something like is you talking to Iron
Man there and there's one showers like
this it looks like Loki might be in
prison but a lot of it is a feeling of
it looks like this it's nothing as clear
they don't really outline at all you
know they're gonna be building to this
giant finale fight it's so in terms of
like teasing the finale it's not really
a spoiler because it so it's an Avengers
movie it's or mashup movie you know
they're gonna get to that point where
they have the giant massive finale fight
I actually think this is a really well
executed trailer while it doesn't
represent any of the humor you don't
really need to communicate that in fact
that was a nice surprise when you watch
the movie that's not like the Iron Man 3
trailer where you're like I thought I
was getting an epic serious Iron Man
movie you know and they're doing this
again with infinity war also as I feel
like with the Avengers films especially
it does pay if these are gonna be the
culmination of phases it does pay to
hype this eviscerate oh yeah of the
battle what's at stake and I think this
trailer does a good job too of just
flowing well enough to make you kind of
forget about picking out where is this
moment gonna come down I'm in the in the
overall structure of the movie you know
where does this fit in the Avengers
movies do a pretty good job at that
the trailers specifically because even
an infinity war I'm like I'm not
entirely sure which one the final battle
is an infinity war yeah I'm more like I
know there's gonna get some big battle
sequences in infinity war
like at what Conda there's the one where
they show spider-man zipping around in
iron man's all injured and [ __ ] like you
got those moments but it's not made
clear like where's the big final battle
there yeah yeah using you with images
and not giving you too much context and
I think that's a that's a nice thing
that they've been able to do with these
especially for the Avengers movies
specifically yeah because these have to
feel like events they're based Huff a
bunch of series that already have to
feel like events so it has to feel like
the event is Tyvek and in that way i
think they do and the stuff that they
choose to give away like that team-up
shot is a pretty huge moment for the
movie but I think that's enough being a
necessary thing to show like don't worry
guys you will see all them on screen at
one time yeah and using that you know
one shot to kind of sum up the movie I
think is actually a pretty nice thing to
do and even though the Hulk catching
Iron Man on Monday we have said about
well they edit it in a way they don't
show that Tony star is gonna go up there
he's gonna try to sacrifice his life to
save the world
yeah they slice it together in a
different way where it looks like he's
going up there someone shoots and Hulk
saves it it's yeah it's the action not
the context so you get all the thrill of
wanting to see that but without knowing
what it is already ya know it's got kind
of all the major themes of the movie in
it it's got a lot of cool yeah they're
gonna entice us and it's even structured
like the first half is about bringing
them together in the second half is
about making them get along to bridge
this conflict and so like in that way it
is kind of a really succinct
advertisement for what this movies gonna
be like what's fascinating about this is
especially after we just watched the
infinity war trailer a couple days ago
and seeing just how different the movies
look now the aspect ratio and the colors
colors and also just the the vibe and
the way all the characters look way they
shoot like wow it's really evolved since
the first Avengers movie you know yeah
infinity war still feels like it'll have
humor within its characters but I doubt
it will have as much of a humorous tone
throughout the way how this Avengers
movie did especially the way age of
Ultron did to know in the way the Russo
brothers have made their past couple
movies there will be yeah there will be
humor but you're gonna feel the weight
of what's at stake yeah for sure this is
a fun trailer to check you out thank you
guys for recommending this one
specifically they're not all bad
all bad I mean they're more fun to break
down the Badger Ahlers is certainly more
of those I think so it was more to come
alright well hey Paige from the day
shout out for Delia Chamberlain Adelia
my dear I know that when you had to have
your surgery you weren't able to catch
the last Jedi in the theaters as your
most anticipated movie and then you had
to recover so you can never make it out
to the theaters and then you were many
match to catch black panther really late
now that you are a little more healed
you will now be able to catch infinity
war on time if you got your presale
tickets I know that in the past few
months 2018 hasn't been the kindest to
you but know that infinity wars around
the corner I know you're excited for it
you're such a sweet person and you've
been so kind to us over our patreon I
loved talking with you I loved I loved
all the message exchanges that we have
over there thank you for being such a
great grand supporter of the channel and
constantly giving feedback to us without
people like you we wouldn't be able to
do what we're doing right now it
wouldn't be and you give a lot of
validation for us honestly you know no
it's part of be self validating but when
I look for external validation you're
one of them to go - sometimes it's nice
to hear from from you know people who
care it seems like about how you're
doing yeah yeah I get that kind of
insight you know you're always very
thoughtful and very thorough and I
appreciate and you can also follow Delia
Chamberlain on the star dust at people
you start posting there because you
found it through us so follow her there
all right guys we can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
about they get notified every time one
of our vids is up and you can check us
out on patreon do that have you please